[Music]
obviously we've spent a pretty good
amount of time around here talking about
the assault on free speech on college
campuses as I've said before I believe
that this assault on free speech is one
of the biggest problems we face today as
we are breeding a generation of young
people who won't be equipped to use
logic and reason in their own arguments
when they graduate to the real world the
university's misguided use of safe
spaces and trigger warnings coupled with
violent protests and D platforming or
shouting down speakers is actually
robbing many of these students of
literally the most important thing that
they can learn in college the ability to
think for themselves instead of
graduating as fully equipped adults
ready to fight for what they believe in
because they know what they believe in
they are being coddled like children who
might crumble at the mere hearing of an
idea that challenges them this inability
to debate ideas is leaking out of the
universities and into society at large
celebrities spent all day on Twitter
ranting and raving about topics that
they don't understand at all
comedians some of whom I know personally
and really liked have become the
screeching lunatics that they're
supposed to be making fun of politicians
talk a lot but don't actually do a lot
and the rest of us are left here trying
to make some sense of what's going on a
great example of this is the title 9
Fiasco which took root on college
campuses over the past few years title 9
is part of the Education Act of 1972
which states that no person in the
United States shall on the basis of sex
be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subjected
to discrimination under any education
program or activity receiving federal
financial assistance well that sounds
pretty good right what we should be
going for here is an even playing field
of equal opportunity title 9 doesn't
guarantee equal outcome which is where
hard work perseverance and sometimes
luck come into play but it does
guarantee that whether you are a man or
a woman you won't be discriminated on
because of your sex this straightforward
law of equal opportunity changed under
the Obama administration which in 2011
and 2014
issued new guidelines on how schools
should deal with cases of sexual assault
on campus while I believe that Obama's
intentions were good the law in effect
circumvented our system of due process
the Obama administration's policy used
the preponderance of evidence standard
in cases of sexual assault
not the beyond-a-reasonable-doubt
standard which reduces the burden of
proof on anyone accused of sexual
assault this was a subtle but powerful
change in how we litigate these cases of
sexual assault on campus and some would
argue an outright violation of the
accused constitutional rights that seem
to boss
Trump's education secretary recently
rescinded these obama mandates and
judging by the celebrity and comedian
critics out there Trump and DeVos were
not only anti-woman
but suddenly pro rape as well my friend
and former guest christina hoff sommers
wrote an excellent piece in the journal
of higher education explaining why
removing the obama guidelines was
actually a win for due process and the
constitution an article i shared with
some of the famous people I saw ranting
about Trump's pro rape policy of course
nobody responded will link to
Christina's article below so that you
can read that for yourself to unpack
title 9 I'll be talking to author and
professor Laura Kipnis today as we
discuss her own story of how title 9 has
affected her both personally and
professionally laura has been right in
the middle of the title 9 firestorm and
our friends at learn Liberty have sent
her our way this week knowing what
you're talking about is a lot harder
than just screaming about how you feel
about something but a good education
taught me that it's usually worth the
effort
[Music]
you